je remercie mon collègue Daniel Brevier
de sa présence régulière
donc vous êtes informé sans doute bien
sûr de
cette mission d'information qui a
démarré déjà depuis fin février donc on
a un petit peu plus qu'à Camille
parcours
on devrait rendre nos travaux donc fin
juin pour une validation début juillet
pour se situer un peu au niveau du
calendrier avec une démarche qui
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans un contexte
qui crée un peu une résonance
particulière sur le sujet donc tant
mieux ça nous permet de peut-être
d'affirmer un peu plus et de souhaiter
une politisation au sens noble du terme
du sujet et je pense que ça va plutôt
dans le bon sens dans ce cas de figure
avec différents travaux différentes
annonces que vous avez bien sûr tous en
tête par rapport à ça c'est une mission
d'information qui a été proposée par le
groupe socialiste écologique et
républicains donc je fais partie le
Président c'est Rémi pointeau elle fait
partie du groupe républicain sachant
qu'on est dans une démarche toujours
transpartisane sur l'émission
d'informations et plus particulièrement
donc au niveau au niveau du Sénat donc
bien évidemment nous rencontrons un
ensemble de parties prenantes le sujet
est relativement large quand on parle
des gestion durable
de l'eau aujourd'hui avec la résonance
bien sûr du varen de l'eau du plan eau
qui a été annoncé récemment et qui
devrait nous permettre d'approfondir
aussi certains sujets qui ont été mis
sur la table et qui méritent aujourd'hui
peut-être
des éclaircissements ce que je vous
propose peut-être dans les propos
liminaires c'est d'une part de vous
présenter pour qu'on vous connaissez
effectivement un peu mieux et puis même
si la fn CCR est assez connue
malgré tout de nous nous représenter
effectivement
cette fédération qui est importante
aujourd'hui et dans les relations bien
sûr que vous pouvez avoir avec les
collectivités sur 18 différents enjeux
sachant qu'un questionnaire vous a été
transmis
on rentrera dans les premières questions
je rebondirai sur vos propos pour on
aura sans doute pas le temps de tout
traiter mais vous nous communiquerez les
éléments par ailleurs que vous souhaitez
par courrier ou par mail par mail de
préférence
facile le travail de Monsieur Sabouret
et même d'ici à 15 jours trois semaines
vous pourront encore nous communiquer
des éléments vous souhaitez porter notre
connaissance
on est travaillera bien évidemment je
vous en prie ce vice-président merci
beaucoup
donc a fait Paul je suis le maire de
Saint-Martin-du-Var dans les
Alpes-Maritimes vice-président de la
Métropole Nice Côte d'Azur en charge de
l'eau l'assainissement et l'énergie je
siège donc à toutes les instances du
comité de la serre
du vice-président du comité d'agrément à
côté de Marcel Sadier donc je siège au
conseil d'administration de l'Agence
depuis 2008 voilà je suis vice-président
de la snccr donc référent du cycle de
l'eau et vice-président du Comité
National de l'Eau qui se tient cet
après-midi d'ailleurs et que j'aurai le
plaisir et l'honneur de présider puisque
notre ami Jean Launay est disponible cet
après-midi voilà peut-être je vais
laisser Cyrielle et Franco se
présentaient avant de rentrer dans les
détails de la fncr
merci donc Cyril Vandewalle donc je
travaille à la FNCCR sur la gestion et
la préservation des ressources en eau
depuis quelques années maintenant donc
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur notamment
la préservation de la ressource par
rapport aux pollutions donc d'origine
agricole et non agricoles et puis je
travaille aussi beaucoup ces derniers
temps sur les aspects de quantité d'eau
et puis d'économie d'eau puisque la fncr
donc anime le club des bonnes pratiques
d'économie d'eau et de tarification
depuis maintenant trois ans donc sur
lequel on travaille beaucoup
je suis franco Novelli je suis la juin
du chef du département cycle de l'eau de
la SNCF et je me charge en particulier
des questions techniques je suis
ingénieur eau potable assainissement
collectif
et là j'ai Mappy également
voilà l'ensemble
ce sujet là
sur certains aspects donc on appuie les
collectivités
adhérentes à la SNCF
principalement sur les aspects
techniques et un appui des collègues à
l'intérieur de la SNCF et puis les
autres associations partenaires
très bien
sa deuxième mission c'est de mettre en
réseau de favoriser les échanges entre
le entre les membres et de partager
aussi les retours d'expérience avec
cette expertise qui s'est vraiment
développée au sein de la FNCCR que ce
soit juridique vraiment technique il y a
vraiment cette cette volonté de mettre
de partager
en prenant en compte évidemment la
grande diversité de nos adhérents
puisqu'on a des adhérents qui
représentent des petits syndicats de
communes et puis de grandes
intercommunalités ou de grands syndicats
inter départementaux parfois donc voilà
c'est cette c'est la richesse de cette
diversité et puis c'est aussi de
représenter bien sûr les adhérents
auprès des pouvoirs publics et donc
c'est un peu
Sud notre rencontre aujourd'hui voilà on
peut dire vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure sur le rapporteur que la fncr
était très active depuis les deux cycles
des assises de l'eau puis le varen de
l'eau agricole puis le plan o et dans la
réforme aussi des redevances des agences
de l'eau puisque c'est un des points qui
sont à l'ordre du jour du Comité
National de l'Eau qui se viendra cet
après-midi à la présentation donc de
cette réforme en profondeur des
redevances des agences de l'eau
sur
la réforme des redevances des agences de
l'eau aujourd'hui
plus précisément c'est une commande de
qui au démarrage c'est une commande du
gouvernement c'est une commande des
parties prenantes
c'est un sujet qui remonte déjà à 2019
l'idée étant que aujourd'hui dans les
produits des agences de l'eau bon il y a
les redevances mais il y a aussi pour
les collectivités il y avait une
contrepartie quelque part qui était un
peu une incitation à bien agir qui était
les redevances pour primer plus rare et
c'est redevances pour que mesurateurs
ont été remises en question par certains
comités d'asserre mais surtout par
l'Europe qui considère que c'est une
subvention de fonctionnement et qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de verser au service
d'eau et d'assainissement enfin au
service d'assainissement en l'occurrence
des des
subventions de fonctionnement dès lors
dans le cas du 12e programme il était
prévu que c'est que ces primes épurateur
disparaissent ce qui a pour effet
mécanique bien pour les contributeurs
qui en bénéficié de voir leur
contribution augmenter et donc il
fallait et puis surtout qu'il y avait
plus du tout de dispositifs incitatifs
aux bonnes pratiques dans les redevances
donc l'idée c'était de d'introduire dans
ce nouveau dispositif ce côté
qui va intervenir à la fois sur les
performances des services d'eau et sur
les performances des systèmes
d'assainissement de chacun des services
d'assainissement ça touche pas que le
système je me permets de faire juste une
assise sur le sujet parce que il faudra
que nous le creusions effectivement un
petit peu plus
c'est pas uniquement le système de
séisme
dans le cas des participations de
financement même sur des redevances de
soutien des tirages il y a des agences
de l'eau qui participent dans le cadre
du budget
sur des coûts de fonctionnement qui
atténue quelque part la participation
des usagers oui alors là on est dans le
domaine des aides des agences de l'eau
on fait d'un côté les aides des agences
de l'eau c'est des dépenses des agences
et les redevances se sont leurs produits
donc là on ne réforme que les redevances
c'est-à-dire les recettes des agences de
l'eau une partie des recettes puisque
enfin la réforme des redevances
prélèvement par exemple est en cours et
dissocié de cette redevance là qui est
une revanche qui est principalement payé
là aujourd'hui par les abonnés
domestiques et assimilés cet article qui
est remise en chantier d'accord du coup
pour purger ce sujet là il y a donc au
niveau du CNE aujourd'hui
des travaux particuliers et donc au
niveau du calendrier qui est proposé
quel était exactement quand est-ce qu'il
y aura une cristallisation alors le CNE
va rendre la vie cet après-midi ensuite
il y a les conférences budgétaires qui
vont approfondir si vous voulez le
les modalités dans le détail parce que
aujourd'hui il y a encore des points
tout n'est pas complètement écrit il y a
notamment sur des indicateurs de
performance il y a des choses qui sont
encore à régler et l'objectif c'est que
cette réforme entre en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2025 avec l'application du des
12e programme des agences de l'eau et le
deuxième donc il faut que ce soit bouclé
en 2024 pour que chaque comité d'acier
puisse ensuite puis se prononcer sur les
taux puisque là il y a un cadre qui est
défini au niveau national mais c'est
bien chaque comité d'asserre par avis
conforme avec le Conseil
d'Administration qui définit les taux de
redevance pour que ces redevances soient
perçus en 2020 à partir de 2025
donc là on est au bout du processus
j'allais dire de concertation et de
dédain la tarification différenciée dans
les objectifs qui sont souhaités pour
aujourd'hui impacter également le
fonctionnement même du modèle économique
des redevances
aujourd'hui on parle de redevance qui
produisent une recette à peu près un
milliard 450 millions d'euros par an
pour les
la proposition qui va être proposée cet
après-midi et de d'asseoir les deux
tiers de 7 redevance c'est-à-dire à peu
près 1 milliard d'euros sur les volumes
consommés d'accord quel que soit les
volumes consommés sur appartement aussi
sur le réseau d'eau potable et les 450
millions restants
répartis sur des objectifs de
performance des services d'eau donc
notamment la connaissance patrimoniale
le niveau de rendement les plans
d'action qui sont mis en oeuvre pour
réduire les fuites et puis les services
de performance des systèmes
d'assainissement performance des
stations d'épuration mais aussi
performance des réseaux de collecte donc
performance équipement performance et
purratoire etc donc sur ces 450 millions
d'euros il y a encore un débat mais
vraisemblablement il y aura ou deux
tiers sur l'eau un tiers sur
l'assainissement au moitié-moitié c'est
pas encore tout à fait arbitré et donc
l'idée étant que lorsque le système
n'est pas performant en applique un
coefficient de 1 et lorsque le système
est performant le coefficient peut
descendre jusqu'à 0,3 sur la part haut
et jusqu'à 0,4 sur la paracellissement
ce qui revient à faire avoir une
réduction de 70% de la redevance là
c'est vraiment incitatif et c'est une
redevance qui sera payé par le service
d'eau donc c'est la pénalisation des
bons élèves alors
non le coefficient c'est 1 lorsque
je me fais l'avocat du diable c'est
juste pour comprendre un peu mieux non
mais si vous devez payer 1000 et que
votre service n'est pas conforme vous
payez 1000 d'accord si votre service est
conforme vous appliquez 03 donc vous
payez 300 au lieu de payer 1000 donc
c'est vraiment incitatif
c'est pas 20% de remise c'est là c'est
70% ou 60 % de remise
alors ça sera répercuté sur la facture
d'eau au titre des redevances ça sera
payé par la Bosnie à la fin c'est
toujours payé par la bonne ça parle oui
de l'abonnés
service n'est pas performant
concernant la redevance mais par contre
c'est bien les bons élèves qui perdront
moins que les mauvais élèves on est
d'accord j'ai bien compris j'ai bien
compris excusez-moi
les redevances sur les prélèvements
professionnels ce qui a une
évolution des calculs de redevance alors
c'est un deuxième chantier qui est mené
en parallèle dans sera plus cet
après-midi parce qu'il y a une
présentation dans le dans le cadre du
plan où justement de l'évolution des
redevances de prélèvement
les propositions qui sont faites par le
ministère et par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui vont dans le sens de mettre
en place des montants plancher de
redevance de prélèvement c'est à dire
que au niveau national sera fixé un
plancher en deux en dessous duquel les
comités d'assaint et les conseils
d'administration ne pourront pas
délibérer et d'une augmentation du
plafond
tu es redevance de prélèvement avec
vraisemblablement donc
à partir du moment où il y a un plancher
l'idée que lorsqu'on prélève de l'eau
dans le milieu naturel
ça doit avoir un coup et on peut pas
avoir des niveaux ou des fois c'était
vraiment trois chiffres après la virgule
le mètre cube donc c'est la vie aucun
sens voilà et on avait des écarts entre
par exemple les redevances de
prélèvements pour l'alimentation en eau
potable et les écarts pour
l'alimentation agricole qui va de 1 à
280 fois par exemple le mètre cube alors
que c'est le même le mètre cube qui est
prélevé dans le même milieu
donc dans la période qu'on vient de
vivre après l'année 2022 il paraît assez
raisonnable de mettre chacun en
responsabilité
voilà
ceci étant le nouveau système va
participer au financement des agences de
l'eau par rapport à l'objectif de 475
millions d'euros on est bien d'accord
alors la redevance dont je vous ai parlé
jusqu'à présent elle a été conçue à
iso-fis qualité puisque les travailleurs
a commencé depuis le mois de depuis
l'été dernier et donc évidemment
personne n'envisageait que que la hausse
des dépenses des agences de l'eau puisse
être un jour à l'ordre du jour temps
elle avait été sacralisée par Bercy si
j'ai pu me permettre
voilà et malgré une belle unanimité donc
aujourd'hui si vous voulez il y a deux
il y a un peu un télescopage entre deux
annonces la réforme des redevances dont
on nous explique elle est vraiment à
iso-fiscalité donc un milliard 450
millions d'euros et en même temps si je
peux utiliser cette expression les plus
475 millions d'euros par an à partir de
2025 dans le cas du 12e programme
dont on ne sait pas encore quel va être
la répartition des efforts demander
parce que c'est des recettes nouvelles
donc c'est pas de l'argent frais nouveau
qui vient c'est pas de l'argent
budgétaire c'est de l'argent des
redevances donc c'est redevances qu'elle
va être la part qui va être supportée
par les usagers domestiques et assimilés
qu'elle va être la part qui va être
supportée par le monde agricole qu'elle
va être la part qui va être supportée
par le monde des industriels et puis par
par le monde de la production d'énergie
à base de à partir de l'eau donc on voit
bien là c'est encore un débat qui n'est
pas tranchée qu'il faudra avoir dans
chaque comité de bassin
mais ces deux sujets en fait qui se
télescopent alors que
que la réforme est construite à produits
je sais pas si je suis clair oui vous
êtes clair mais c'est un sujet en soi
[Musique]
et que
la part
de ces de l'ensemble des produits des
agences de l'eau qui affecté dans le cas
du 11e programme au petit cycle de l'eau
c'est à peu près 34%
d'accord donc on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les usagers
domestiques et assimilés qui finance
les politiques environnementales
déjà la politique de l'ofb mais aussi
toutes les actions en faveur des milieux
qui sont portés et subventionnés par les
agences de l'eau
puisque les recettes des agences qui
proviennent des redevances agricoles
sont à peu près équilibrées elles sont
un peu inférieures aux aides d'en
bénéficier des agriculteurs des agences
de l'eau en tous les cas sur le c'est le
cas en RMC et les industriels aussi mais
ça correspondent à des petits montants
donc c'est à peu près équilibré
la grosse le gros financeur des agences
de l'eau et de tout politique
environnementale c'est l'usager
domestique et la position de la snccr
c'est que à l'occasion de cette
augmentation des des plafonds de
dépenses des agences de l'eau il soit
procédé à un rééquilibrage des
contributions des différents usagers de
l'eau notamment
sur la production
d'énergie à base de l'eau qui
aujourd'hui est un vraiment piètre
contributeur au sens que ces
contributions sont vraiment très
marginales par rapport
par rapport à
son chiffre d'affaires et par rapport si
vous voulez à l'intérêt qu'il y a vous
allez glisser dans le cahier des charges
de la mise en concurrence des barrages
hydroélectriques donc des redevances
complémentaires je vais pas rentrer dans
ce début
mais en tous les cas force ces deux
constater en tout cas
indirectement c'est quand même ce que
vous indique parce que vous indiquez
sur ce sujet
par rapport à ça
bon c'est un sujet qu'on voit bien sûr
approfondir parce qu'il est quand même
majeur aujourd'hui juste peut-être pour
clôturer cet aspect est-ce que vous avez
une vision aujourd'hui des modèles
européens pour voir comment la France se
situe par rapport à ça puisque
à chaque fois qu'on interroge les
politiques européennes il y a toujours
justement cette approche à la fois
concurrentielle qui est mis sur la table
mais c'est intéressant aussi de regarder
d'une manière un peu comparative comment
les autres pays européens fonctionnent
et se comportent ce que vous avez cette
expertise
non pas directement enfin on n'a pas une
vision globale pays par pays après
ensuite on a on a des rapports avec des
associations qui œuvrent au niveau
européen
on sait par exemple qui est des
questions de de redevance pollueurs
payeurs
sont par exemple dans le cadre de la
révision de la directive européenne
aux résidus
qui est en cours
des mécanismes qui sont qui sont
envisagés
reposent sur une entité à une entité
indépendante qui doit collecter les
résultats les produits des des
redevances pollutions mais notamment
pour les industriels enfin ils
n'existent pas dans d'autres pays le
même système que en France de collecte
de redevance aux pollution modernisation
de réseau donc ce sont d'autres entités
donc dans ce cadre là par exemple nous
on mettait en avant qu'il faut préserver
le mécanisme français et pas se faire
imposer une entité
parallèle pour gérer ces questions
c'est pas forcément le cas
je n'ai pas forcément un avis là dessus
mais pas de souci mais le sujet peut
être intéressant quand même aujourd'hui
pour analyser un peu mieux effectivement
nos positionnement pour avancer donc
dans la dans le questionnement et puis
dans les messages aussi que vous
souhaitez nous faire passer
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'en
termes d'acceptabilité il faut qu'on
arrive à tracer des voies pour que les
conflits d'usage soient le plus illimité
possible mais c'est plus facile à dire
aujourd'hui qu'à faire ceci étant les
ptge sont une voie qui effectivement
semble pertinente mais on voit bien
qu'il faut que les la méthodologie soit
fines et bien respectées pour qu'ils
puissent conduire à une réussite
vous avez sans doute des niveaux
d'analyse aussi par rapport à ça on
souhaiterait les partager avec vous sur
la gouvernance on va aller assez vite
gouvernance bassin etc tout le monde
partage aujourd'hui elles optb les sages
est-ce que vous avez quelques messages à
nous faire passer sur cette approche de
gouvernance par comité de bassin au
niveau des agences de l'eau les EPTB les
sages pour arriver au sous bassin est-ce
que vous avez des propositions à faire
dans ce cadre dans ce cadreau dans ce
cadre plus particulièrement et puis sur
la consommation domestique on voit que
depuis quelques temps il y avait des
efforts de sobriété qui étaient faits
mais on est aujourd'hui plutôt sur un
plancher quel est votre niveau d'analyse
aussi par rapport à ça et en perspective
de la tarification différenciée comment
vous abordez éventuellement ce sujet et
comment améliorer donc ces politiques de
sobriété
alors on va peut-être commencer par par
l'organisation la gouvernance
la position de la snccr c'est que
imposer des sages partout c'est pas la
meilleure façon d'agir rapidement au
plus près des territoires
pourquoi parce que lorsqu'il y a un
territoire qui décide aujourd'hui de se
lancer dans l'aventure de la
construction de laboration d'un sage en
moyenne des sages qui aboutissent
aujourd'hui ont été lancés il y a 10 ans
donc si on se lance en 2023 dans
l'élaboration d'un sage avant 2033 il
n'y a pas d'effet concret à part la
discussion à part faire un dossier de 5
ou 600 pages après à être passé devant
dix commissions à tous les échelons bien
sûr
local départemental régional national
donc
si on veut agir vite et je crois que la
situation aujourd'hui nous l'impose
même si je veux ouvrir une petite
parenthèse quand même parce que la
pluviométrie qu'on a pu avoir là un
petit peu cet automne dans une grande
partie de la France fait déjà oublier
les effets de la sécheresse de 2022 moi
je suis en début des Alpes-Maritimes je
peux vous dire que quand on est élu des
anne-maritimes
voilà non mais je le dis parce que
certains territoires dire mais nous mais
ça y est les ressources sont
reconstituées mais c'est un épiphénomène
je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas la
sécheresse qui est le qui est le
l'épiphénomène c'est malheureusement
dans
les années qui viennent il va falloir
revoir le modèle de construction et j'en
reviens à la première partie de votre
question
qui était l'élaboration des ptge en
résonne aujourd'hui sur la base des
moyennes des 10 dernières années en
matière de volume prélevables sauf que
les volumes prélevables des PPG qui ont
été élaborés l'année dernière sur la
base des dix dernières années on est
déjà complètement décalé parce que
l'idée c'est d'assurer la l'alimentation
en eau de 4 années sur 5 mais quand on a
des références
et c'est exactement ce que j'allais dire
c'est qu'il faudrait être capable
d'anticiper les ppge sur la base de
l'eau qui sera disponible au cours des
10 prochaines années pas celles dont on
a pu bénéficier au cours des 10 ou des
dés qui viennent de s'écouler et donc là
on introduit un billet et on introduit à
travers les ptge quelques dans la tête
des participants un espèce de droit doux
parce que c'est un peu comme ça que
c'est perçu un droit de prélèvement qui
est complètement décalé par rapport à
l'eau qui est disponible aujourd'hui
donc ça c'est un biais
ensuite je vous ai parlé des sages c'est
pas parce que on n'a pas 10 ans pour
faire un sage qu'on doit rien faire et
dans les territoires qui ont subi
l'année dernière des manques d'oie
importants on voit où il y a une tension
entre les usages bon s'il y a les
acteurs se sont pas encore mieux autour
de la table mais il y a la possibilité
avec les comités de bassin qui
connaissent bien le territoire le son
maillage tous les niveaux c'est
inversant par bassin versant avec les
préfectures d'organiser quelque part des
acides de l'eau au niveau local au
niveau du territoire au niveau du seau à
Saint-Vincent pour mettre déjà les
acteurs autour de la table pour discuter
ensemble de l'eau avant d'élaborer un
sage parce que punir en plus en disant
si vous n'avez pas de Sage vous allez
être pénalisé mais enfin c'est pas c'est
pas ça qui va qui va faire en sorte que
les gens se retrouvent les manches quoi
voilà donc partir des choses simples
partir du constat de la réalité et
essayer de se fixer des objectifs qui
soient en adéquation avec la quantité
dont on va pouvoir bénéficier dans le
futur et pas celle qui était disponible
jusqu'à présent mais dans ce cas de
figure comment affirmer
la notion de préconisation et la notion
de voilà qui est quand même un document
qui permette de fixer des grandes
orientations voire de les imposer aussi
exactement l'idée de ce qui se fait à
peu près ce qui a évolué dans les
papilles c'est à dire avec un papy
d'intention on pourrait très bien
envisager qu'avant de faire un sage pur
et dur et qui respecte l'ensemble du
formalisme on pourrait avoir comme pour
les papiers un stage d'intention avec
quelques grandes orientations déjà qui
qui
adresse j'allais dire des des actions
immédiates enfin dans les vraiment de
très court terme et ensuite lorsqu'on a
déjà commencé à travailler sur sur
justement
quelle quantité d'eau disponible pour
faire quoi et pour qui
élaborer un document plus plus construit
avec des perspectives de long terme plus
transversales mais si on attend le grand
jour où on a le super document pour agir
et là qui vont tirer la langue mais je
reviens à ma question prescription
préconisations à un moment donné quand
on veut mettre en place des politiques
il y a aussi des axes d'orientation nous
travaillons nous aussi pour inscrire
d'une manière plus dynamique la gestion
de l'eau dans les documents d'urbanisme
Scott et pluie parce que ça nous semble
aujourd'hui au travers de beaucoup
d'auditions partagés d'ailleurs un
élément qui est quand même assez
déterminant
c'est vrai que les politiques de l'eau
devraient être mieux prises en compte
déjà depuis l'estradettes jusqu'à
au PLU
voilà on est d'accord là dessus
maintenant décrété que il faut que
chacun se
à travailler sur la question de l'eau
on peut le décrypter on peut l'imposer
on peut sanctionner les gens qui le font
pas enfin je pense que la position de la
fncca c'est de dire qu'il faut
convaincre et il faut pas forcer ou
sanctionner il faut arriver à amener les
gens dans l'action plutôt que les
stigmatiser lorsque parce que aux
endroits où sur les parties du
territoire où il n'y a pas
d'organisation aujourd'hui
on parle de prescription
que c'est pas fait très vite on arrive à
dire oui mais vous vous avez pas
expliqué le faire voilà bref pour vous
c'est la bonne volonté alors non il faut
inciter la bonne volonté il faut
rassembler j'ai dit sous l'égide des
comités d'asserre et des préfets donc un
CT avec des développements de politique
conditionnelle à court terme déjà agir à
court terme pour après réfléchir
ensemble à des politiques plus
transversales plus plus larges sur le
toujours sur le même périmètre de la
salvertants mais mais
on soit bien au club vous êtes d'accord
sur la conditionnalité dans ce cas dans
ce cas de figure
moi ça me gêne pas ouais personnellement
je suis d'accord
ce qui refuse de de ceux qui font
l'Autriche je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
forcément voilà
pas du tout non donc oui c'est vrai que
l'eau doit être mieux prise en compte
dans l'ensemble des politiques
que j'ai évoquées de programmation
notamment
l'idée c'est aussi
je discute avec des responsables de
services d'eau il nous dit voilà tiens
l'État le préfet a signé un accord avec
un industriel qui vient installer une
entreprise chez moi c'est super il va
créer 20 emplois il a besoin d'un
million et demi de mètres cubes d'eau
par an
il me dit ben monsieur le Président il
va falloir aller chercher un million de
mètres cubes parce que là on a signé la
boîte à s'implanté
est-ce que c'est comme ça encore qu'on
doit faire l'aménagement du territoire
aujourd'hui et est-ce qu'il faut pas se
poser la question quand on aime on
implante une entreprise qui est
génératrice de beaucoup de consommation
d'eau est-ce qu'il faut pas l'installer
à l'endroit où il y a de l'eau enfin je
sais pas si peut-être c'est moi qui suis
décalé je sais pas
lorsqu'on va installer à l'agriculteur
sur des terrains qui étaient laissés en
recherche parce que c'est il faut de
l'agriculture nourricière et que ça va
bien on va faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'arrosage et on se dit je vais aller
chercher l'eau donc j'ai pas assez d'eau
là donc je vais aller chercher l'eau à
100 ou 200 km parce qu'il y a pas d'eau
est-ce que 6 à cet endroit là qu'il faut
implanter ce type de production
donc ça c'est peut-être se poser ces
questions là qui sont pas des questions
très juridiques mais on revient un petit
peu au bon sens paysan moi je suis
agriculteur donc je veux dire voilà dans
un village de 200 habitants dans le Zap
de Provence la ruralité je sais ce que
c'est mais à l'époque ça serait jamais
venu à l'idée de nos parents ou de nos
grands-parents et de faire des choses
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est un du c'est à
dire on fait une entreprise ben
forcément on doit amener la route on
doit amener le gaz on doit amener l'eau
on a bien compris ça renforce l'intérêt
d'une planification qui soit vraiment
partagée c'est à dire que la gestion de
la ressource au niveau d'un Scott ça
veut dire ben il y a aussi tant de
mètres cubes qui sont aussi disponibles
sur un territoire comment on accueille à
la fois les populations les activités
dans les meilleures conditions donc là
dessus je pense qu'on est on est
effectivement bien au clair par rapport
à ça mais ça renvoie aussi des
phénomènes d'attractivité de territoire
qui sont en surchauffe et qui à un
moment donné accueille des populations
alors qu'ils en ont pas forcément les
moyens
c'est aussi des activités économiques
mais pas que les activités économiques
quand on y regarde un peu plus près
cette planification territoriale des
territoires qui gagnent beaucoup de
population alors que la ressource en eau
est aussi défaire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
vous évoquiez le
plancher un petit peu dans la baisse des
consommations d'eau par les usagers
domestiques
sur les territoires qui ont une forte
progression démographique je pense à
Montpellier je pense à Rennes faire
Bordeaux ou autre enfin je veux dire il
y a des territoires qui sont quand même
beaucoup plus attractifs enfin en tous
les cas on est en oeuvre des politiques
qui pour attirer de la population
même si on a une baisse de 1% des
consommations si vous avez 20%
d'augmentation de la population en 10
ans il va bien falloir trouver de l'eau
mais comme l'eau disponible sur la le
territoire de proximité
n'a pas tendance à augmenter on va la
chercher plus loin
et donc après se pose la question de
justement de la protection de ces airs
d'alimentation des champs de captage
pose la question de quel usage on fait
de ces terrains-là je rappelle que la
totalité des surfaces des airs
d'alimentation de chambre de captage
c'est 3% de la surface agricole utile
et la position de la SNCF c'est de dire
que sur ces 3% de la surface agricole
utile il faut que dans les 10 ans on est
purement et simplement arrêter
de d'utiliser des produits chimiques sur
ces 3% là c'est à dire qu'il faut plus
faire de l'agriculture sur lequel on a
bien suivi ce sujet mais sur lesquels la
filarricole demande des compensations
oui mais c'est pas les compensations
elles partent à la vie de la SNCF elle
part déjà du modèle agricole qu'on
choisit si l'agriculteur qui travaille
sur une aire d'alimentation de captage a
le même modèle économique d'agriculteur
qui a une obligation de faire de la
production intensive et alors le système
de fonctionne pas et ça veut dire que
c'est avec la facture d'eau qu'on va
payer le kilo de blé d'accord il y a
d'autres possibilités de faire de
l'agriculture qui existent avec des
modèles moins
extensifs et qui permettent à
l'agriculteur de vivre du produit de ses
revenus si sur 3% de la surface agricole
utile en développer ce ayant on dit pas
il faut le faire l'année prochaine ça
donne 10 ans pour le faire ça m'a sur le
vice-président on connaît bien il y a
juste un sujet
qui pose question aujourd'hui puis après
je vais ouvrir la parole à mes collègues
c'est oui on peut très bien mais pour
accompagner malgré tout les nouveaux
modèles il faut aussi une politique
d'accompagnement quelque part c'est pas
du jour au lendemain non mais ils ont
pas la capacité non plus de le faire du
jour au lendemain donc qui paye et
comment ça existe les agences de l'eau
paye aujourd'hui des PSE les prestations
pour service environnementaux moi je dis
toujours dans l'agence de l'eau il
faudrait il manque un r un PSE pour
service prestation pour service
environnementaux rendus
parce que parfois on peut
j'ai la faiblesse de croire que les
services environnementaux sont supposés
ou sont attendus j'aimerais bien qu'on
paye pour les services rendus
il y a le service fait et il y a le
service rendu ce qui pose et pas le
service attendu ou imaginez
la qualité de l'évaluation des
compensations et des services rendus qui
aujourd'hui est un vrai sujet pour nous
dans notre pays je vais peut-être si mes
collègues bonne intervenir parce que je
suis en prie
je réagissais parce que effectivement ce
sont des des sujets très importants que
que vous évoquez là et la notion de 3%
je n'avais pas en tête mais la question
de l'accompagnement derrière
l'ingénierie de qui coordonne qui est va
devenir quand même doit devenir un sujet
mais sur les objectifs vraiment je les
partage mais ça peut pas se faire du
jour au lendemain
mais il faut peut-être alors est-ce
qu'il faut seulement inciter accompagner
ou derrière donner un certain nombre
voilà de
si ce n'est pas de compensation mais
d'aller plus loin moi je suis en
Bretagne donc c'est un sujet assez voilà
c'est prégnant mais moi je partage tout
à fait les objectifs vraiment que que
vous citez vraiment mais après comment
on fait parce que c'est bien de dire moi
je mais après faut faire voilà oui sur
le même sujet parce que ce sujet qui me
préoccupe beaucoup c'est vrai que nos
collectivités nos syndicats des eaux
beaucoup ont eu affaire aux
problématiques de
demesola chlor vous avez été beaucoup
interpellé par les collectivités donc
aujourd'hui on a 500 + 500 captages
prioritaires quel est le bilan que vous
faites des politiques sur ces sur ces
captages prioritaires et je crois sur
les 35000 sur les 35000 captages
à combien de captages vous évoluez ceux
qui aujourd'hui enfin on va dire dans
les trois ans sont concernés par des
problématiques de voilà de pollution et
après je reviens à ce que disait ma
collègue comment on fait
alors je vais essayer de répondre à la
première partie de la question et je
laisserai Franco vous parler de la
protection de chanteur parce que c'est
vraiment un spécialiste de ces questions
là
comment on fait comment on fait pour
pour mettre en oeuvre les propositions
de la snccr sur les 3 % de la surface
agricole dans le cas des assises de
l'eau la SNCF a apporté une mesure qui
était assez novatrice qui était de dire
que sur les périmètres d'alimentation
des argumentations de champ de captage
il fallait que le service d'eau soit
ayant droit de prévention prioritaire
pour pouvoir faire l'acquisition de ces
terrains
c'est un sujet qui fonctionne d'ailleurs
au de Paris travail avec des
agriculteurs qui sont sur des périmètres
donc d'alimentation des gens de captage
qui sont mobilisés par route de Paris
pour alimenter les la capitale en eau
potable et cela a apporté des résultats
qui sont très intéressants mais s'ils
font ça depuis des années ça fait sur
les PSE
donc premièrement on permet au service
d'eau d'acquérir ces terrains et à
partir du moment on est propriétaires du
terrain déjà on peut donner à bague bien
sûr agricole
ces terrains-là mais avec un cahier des
charges si vous voulez
ou des bois environnementaux donc on a
cette possibilité là ensuite il y a les
aides je suis d'accord avec vous on
passe pas du jour au lendemain d'un
système à l'autre donc il y a une
période de transition la période de
transition elle doit être accompagnée et
la position de la snccr c'est de dire
c'est bien on va mettre là dans le cadre
du du plan o 100 millions d'euros pour
accompagner les agriculteurs mais 100
millions d'euros c'est ridicule c'est
pas assez c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
changer de paradigme on va accompagner
quelques opérations expérimentales mais
on va pas changer de braquer
pour changer braquet ce qu'il faut vous
parliez de de l'Europe tout à l'heure il
faut vraiment que la France s'empare de
ces questions à travers la Pâques et
qu'en réoriente des crédits de la PAC
sur justement l'accompagnement au
changement de
au changement de pratique agricole et là
il y a des moyens qui sont bien plus
considérables que que l'argent de la
facture d'eau de de Monsieur Madame
Michu qui économise chaque saut pour
arroser leur géranium pour payer les 100
millions d'euros aux agriculteurs donc
voyez c'est une question de d'échelle et
il y a une question de volonté de
changer ou pas de modèle
sur ces 3% là sur les champs 14 j'ai
laissé la parole à Franco Develier
oui vous aviez parlé des pollution les
amateurs et ces métabolites il y en a
d'autres qui arrivent aussi avec le Rota
le Nil et chlorure enfin des herbicides
de fongicides utilisés en agriculture
conventionnelle
alors les captages dit prioritaires bon
sont
pas tous ceux qui devraient être
concernés par ces pollutions globalement
ceux qui ont fait l'objet des programmes
des plans d'action et ben on note quand
même une amélioration sur les molécules
qui étaient suivies et historiquement
les pollutions anciennes si on tient
compte des nouvelles molécules ben ça ne
change pas grand chose
et aujourd'hui on sait bien qu'avec les
dernières molécules c'est plus des la
moitié de ressources
en eau qui sont concernés contaminés
et et plus d'un tiers des des eaux
potable qui qui sera non conforme aux
normes de potabilité actuelle donc
ça remet en cause en fait
on est plus on n'est plus en mesure de
respecter nos propres règles en matière
de production d'eau potable
si on devait mettre en place des
traitements
pour qu'ils soient efficace
ça coûterait des milliards alors
je savais peut-être utile des adresser
des fléchis ces moyens à la transition
des exploitations agricoles plutôt que
de
payer des traitements
qu'on ne peut pas d'ailleurs mettre en
oeuvre partout
certainement les les grands
agglomérations ont les moyens la
technicité et puis aussi des endroits
pour rejeter les eaux polluées issus des
ces traitements là
chose qu'on ne peut pas faire en
campagne au niveau des captages isolés
et puis en mettant un oeuvre des
techniques des technologies qui sont
très consommatrices d'énergie
qui demande de ressources qui
proviennent d'ailleurs
ce qu'on les a pas en France donc se
rend dépendant extrêmement dépendant
pour produire d'eau potable c'est quand
même
c'est pas une bonne voie enfin en tout
cas la mission est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a une débat public en course sur
l'osmose inverse
beaucoup estimé pour le sédive quand
même à 2 milliards par exemple qui sur
la note d'eau des Franciliens un peu
c'est quand même 20 centimes je crois
quelque chose comme ça au mètre cube
mais qui est absorbable mais
cette technique n'est pas peut pas être
généralisée et puis par ailleurs c'est
vrai que s'il y a quand même une un
problème de conception de se dire qu'au
fond on va investir des milliards sur le
traitement plutôt que d'investir ces
milliards sur la prévention quoi mais
vous citiez un sujet que je connais pas
de ressources c'est pour cette méthode
là il y a besoin de de ressources
importées c'est ça
pour cette méthode là
on peut peut-être trouver les oui le en
général ce que
ce qu'on met en oeuvre comme traitement
lorsqu'on n'utilise pas la l'osmose
inversé basse pression c'est charbon
actif charbon actif on les fait venir
d'ailleurs
il faut les régénérer à des à des
fréquences des plus en plus élevées 4 5
fois plus élevé que les fréquences
anciennes donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
les retirer il faut les envoyer en
traitement oui essentiellement
comment ça se doter de
technique de traitement individuel
maintenant
je veux bien effectivement
éclaircir un peu un point donc sur
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs il y a
quand même de l'expertise qui existe
maintenant depuis plusieurs années dans
les territoires sur la transition
agroécologique il y a des exploitations
qui ont fait leur transition
agroécologie qui est qui s'en sortent et
là dans nos propositions en fait il
s'agissait d'accompagner les
agriculteurs des aires d'alimentation de
captage avec un objectif dans 10 ans en
concertation avec eux pour justement
choisir en fait les étapes sur 10 ans
pour essayer de faire cette transition
agroécologique et évidemment avec un
accompagnement personnalisé mais ça ça
peut pas se faire en fait sans
l'impulsion du gouvernement il faut une
vraie impulsion du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet là il y a certaines aires
d'alimentation de captage dans
lesquelles il y a des concertations en
cours justement pour
définir des étapes sur 10-15 ans pour
aboutir finalement
au zéro pesticides de synthèse utilisé
sur ces aires d'alimentation de captage
dans 10 à 15 ans donc on est
effectivement conscient que ça ça prend
du temps mais plus on attend voilà plus
plus on va tarder et il nous semble
qu'il faut juste il faudrait justement
dans ce problème de transition
agroécologie donc qui est qui est
souhaitée mais très compliqué on
pourrait faire des terres d'alimentation
de captage justement des territoires
expérimentaux pour cette transition
agroécologie qui pourront servir ensuite
à d'autres territoires sur lesquels il y
a pas forcément d'air d'alimentation de
captage
mais où il y a une volonté du coup de de
faire cette transition pour revenir sur
sur Eau de Paris donc effectivement ils
ont un paiement pour service
environnemental donc qui est en cours
c'est une mesure qui a dû être notifié à
la Commission européenne parce qu'on a
beaucoup de réglementations sur les
aides agricoles qui contraignent
l'action des collectivités pour
accompagner les agriculteurs dans leur
transition
et donc les processus de notification
d'aide agricole sont quand même très
complexes donc effectivement au Paris a
réussi et a priori leur PSE semble
fonctionner et donner des résultats donc
c'est très intéressant mais du coup il
faut rappeler que c'est pas à la portée
de toutes les collectivités
voilà et après sur sur le bilan de la
politique des captages prioritaires donc
effectivement on a quand même des
collectivités qui ont mis en place des
plans d'action depuis une bonne dizaine
plus de 10 ans d'ailleurs plus de 10 ans
avec donc parfois des résultats donc
comme Eau de Paris qui a eu des
résultats au du bassin rennais aussi a
mis en place mais aussi des politiques
très innovantes pour protéger ses airs
d'alimentation de captage donc il y a
des résultats
justement alors on peut avant même là on
peut en profiter de révision déjà vous
voyez crantée pour éviter aussi de
perdre trop de temps mais ça serait
intéressant parce que du coup c'est
aussi un partage des Scotts ont aussi se
méritent d'être dans une négociation
commune au niveau des collectivités
concernées et du coup on identifie tous
les périmètres de captage et derrière on
peut identifier aussi des zones et des
zonages particuliers sur lesquels on va
essayer de travailler la reconversion et
ses approchas oui évidemment en fait ce
serait très intéressant justement enfin
c'est la mise en cohérence de toutes les
politiques publiques et en fait mettre
en cohérence les politiques de
développement rural d'alimentation
avec les politiques publiques de l'eau
et avec les politiques publiques
d'aménagement ce serait évidemment
beaucoup plus cohérent
forcément ça c'est intéressé d'ailleurs
d'un peu plus près c'est intéressant
aussi dans l'approche le temps passe
malheureusement je vous rappelle que les
éléments qu'on n'aura pas pu aborder sur
lesquels vous voulez faire passer un
message on est communiquerez il y a
vraiment aucun souci on serait on y sera
très attentif je voudrais quand même
revenir sur un sujet au niveau des
collectivités sur le sentiment d'un
sous-investissement des collectivités
notamment sur l'entretien des réseaux et
pour le coup les réseaux fuyants
aujourd'hui qui nécessiterait certains
employés ce terme un véritable plan
Marshall pour arriver donc quel est
votre vision peut-être aussi sur sur le
sujet et puis ça pose bien sûr le
délicat la délicate question de la
gestion différenciée en fonction des
collectivités et de leurs capacité aussi
à faire donc on connaît bien le débat au
niveau du Sénat par rapport à ça sur la
bataille au niveau de l'intégration dans
les communautés de communes des
syndicats des eaux mais aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a un point de vue même si
il est peut-être difficile pour vous au
niveau de la FNCCR sur ce sujet là
est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il vaut mieux promouvoir
des systèmes qui reposent sur une
assiette suffisamment large pour pouvoir
accompagner les programmes qu'est-ce
qu'il en est
la fnssr elle représente plus de 600
collectivités 90% de la population
des servi en nous en France donc elle a
quand même une assise représentative sa
position est très claire c'est que
un service d'eau qui n'a pas une taille
critique ne peut pas mener à bien une
politique ambitieuse de l'eau politique
ambitieuse c'est quoi c'est la
protection de la qualité la continuité
du service de l'eau c'est à dire faire
face aux aléas climatiques et puis mener
une politique d'investissement
d'ailleurs il est surprenant aujourd'hui
que les dérogations
qui a existé à l'époque avant la loi
neutre continuent à s'appliquer c'est à
dire que lorsque vous êtes dans une
commune de moins de 1000 habitants vous
avez tout un tas de dérogations qui vous
qui vous permettent de ne pas appliquer
la loi sur l'eau c'est à dire d'avoir un
budget sincère d'avoir un budget annexe
etc etc et souvent ces petites
collectivités elles ont des tarifs de
loups qui bat toute
il y a pas de concurrence possible c'est
normal puisque c'est avec l'impôt qu'on
paye le cantonnier c'est avec l'impôt
qu'on paye le véhicule c'est avec
l'impôt qu'on paye les tuyaux lorsqu'on
doit en changer donc il y a déjà cette
question de la sincérité des budgets
d'eau à partir du moment où on applique
la loi neutre c'est à dire que on passe
à une taille de service qui est au moins
pas inférieur à celui de
l'intercommunalité la position de la
SNCF c'est surtout de pas dire il y a un
modèle qui a un bon modèle
on a des services qui sont des services
de grandes collectivités qui gèrent que
la collectivité qui ont des tailles
critiques qui permettent d'avoir une
vraie mise en oeuvre de politique il y a
le système des intercommunalités qui
fonctionnent bien il y a le système des
syndicats intercommunaux des syndicats
inter départementaux donc chaque taille
les SPL chacun a le droit d'avoir son
manque d'organisation par contre ce
qu'on peut pas c'est rester seul dans
son coin comme le village gaulois et se
plaindre qu'on n'a pas assez d'aide et
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire les choses
bien je pense que chaque habitant du
territoire français a le droit d'avoir
de l'eau il y a le droit d'avoir de
l'eau potable et comme je dis qu'il a le
droit d'avoir de l'eau potable
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas parce que
les contrôles dans ces petits services
sont quasi inexistants
d'accord et lorsqu'il y a un contrôle je
peux vous en parler savamment souvent
l'agent du laboratoire qui vient faire
le prélèvement il a prévenu une semaine
avant et il est accompagné par quelqu'un
du service d'eau
c'est-à-dire que si on faisait ça dans
les grands services on aurait 105% de
conformité non mais moi j'ai dit les
choses on est là pour se dire les choses
aussi donc il y a deux poids de mesure
aujourd'hui et je pense que chaque
citoyen a le droit en France en 2023
d'avoir de l'eau et d'avoir de l'eau
potable voilà sur les réseaux fuyants le
plan Marshall sur le sur le plan
Marshall là aussi il faut pas se tromper
entre le volume financier d'argent qui
est mis dans les renouvellements de
canalisation et l'efficacité de l'argent
qui est mis il y a une question
déficience qui se pose
on peut très bien dépenser 2% de son de
son budget à faire du rendement de
canalisation sans améliorer les
performances du réseau
si vous renouvelez des canalisations qui
sont en bon état et que vous n'allez pas
intervenir la non mais c'est vrai mais
c'est le cas
ça arrive on fait une route nouvelle on
dit bah alors on va pas être embêté
parce que je reviens pas pendant 20 ans
donc je change de tuyau de l'utilisation
on se pose pas la question c'est le
tuyau a été posé il y a 20 ans et qui va
durer 80 ans ce qui est pas le cas de la
route la route d'ici 80 ans va vous dire
la refaire donc on va changer le tuyau
alors oui je peux dépenser beaucoup
d'argent à poser des tuyaux bon ça fait
plaisir au moins certaines industries de
changer des tuyaux mais la question
c'est pas ça la question c'est pas quel
est le volume financier d'argent ou quel
est le linéaire de canalisation que je
remplace c'est de quels outils je
dispose pour mettre là ce que je mets un
million d'euros pour améliorer au
maximum le rendement de réseau donc il
faut connaître son réseau ce qu'on
appelle la gestion patrimoniale et puis
il faut aussi travailler et aujourd'hui
de plus en plus de services qui le
mettent en œuvre avec l'intelligence
artificielle pour savoir quels sont les
secteurs les plus fouillards travailler
aussi sur la pression de service il y a
des moyens mais pour le coup
à ce moment-là il faut affirmer les
conditionnalités dans la connaissance
fine de son patrimoine et il faut que
aujourd'hui des syndicats soient en
mesure d'avoir une vision qui soit la
plus exacte possible sur laquelle il
devrait adosser un programme plus réel
d'investissement qui soit inscrit dans
un modèle économique forcément calculé
ce qui est loin d'être toujours le cas
c'est un des critères qui retenus pour
la redevance de performance des services
d'eau et d'assainissement dont je vais
vous parler en introduction d'accord
je pense qu'on peut qui souscrire
n'est-ce pas ça rejoint nous aussi la
démarche un peu plus globale que l'on
essaye aussi d'approfondir sur l'intérêt
de contrats d'objectifs et de
performance à tous les niveaux quand on
y regarde un peu plus près à tous les
niveaux je vais revenir sur la
tarification vous m'avez interrogé sur
la tarification en deux minutes
peut-être pour dire que
la tarification progressive qui a été
évoquée dans les 53 mesures du plan o
c'est une possibilité ce d'être une
possibilité qui offerte au service la
position de la FNSE CCR c'est que chaque
service d'eau doit mettre en oeuvre en
fonction de la réalité de son territoire
une tarification qui est adaptée et ce
qui paraît le plus important lorsqu'on
change le mode de facturation sur un
service d'eau c'est d'avoir déjà la
connaissance très fine c'est-à-dire
presque exhaustive de la segmentation de
ces consommateurs c'est à dire lorsque
je vais mettre je vais agir sur tel
levier qu'est-ce que ça comme impact sur
combien d'abonnés sur quel abonné avant
de parce que les grandes idées de ça
peut provoquer des effets des effets
secondaires qui sont catastrophiques sur
le terrain et souvent qu'ils ont
contre-productif c'est à dire qu'on veut
atteindre l'objectif et plein de bonnes
intentions on va à l'encontre des des
souhaits qu'on veut qu'on veut porter
donc déjà il faut cette connaissance là
cette connaissance là c'est une
banquérisation des consommateurs des
profils de consommateur et faire des
simulations ça c'est la première chose
là tarification progressive je peux en
parler puisque sur Nice de l'avant mise
en oeuvre depuis 2015 donc on a été
parmi les précurseurs 3 tranches 0,60 m3
60 20 au-delà de 120 mètres cubes
d'accord donc par rapport à la terre
on avait une isofacture à 350 mètres
cubes
ce qui est vrai à Nice n'est pas
forcément vrai à Cannes ou n'est pas
forcément vrai à Paris ou à Montpellier
ce la position de la SNCF c'est de dire
il faut arriver à mettre en place une
tarification différenciée notamment
lorsqu'on a par exemple des résidences
secondaires les tarifications
saisonnières ou des tarifications des
résidences secondaires c'est possible
aujourd'hui on sait qu'elles sont les
logements qui sont occupés à l'année et
les autres pourquoi parce que c'est en
fait la consommation marginale qui
définit les besoins du service le
service on le dimensionne pas sur les
besoins moyens en le dimensionne sur le
besoin de pointe d'accord et donc c'est
pour les quelques centaines de résidents
qui viennent passer 15 jours par an
qu'on renforce les capacités de
production les réservoirs la capacité de
stockage les diamètres des canalisations
etc
mais trouver de l'eau lorsqu'il fait
moins 30 dehors à 2000 mètres d'altitude
c'est compliqué mais par contre quand là
les gens ils prennent tous deux à trois
douches par jour enfin je veux dire vous
rentrez du ski le matin etc etc l'eau
poulet juste
différentielle oui oui on est d'accord
on est d'accord je pense mais comment va
faire là cette histoire parce que le
gouvernement
souhaite mettre en place une mission
d'information parlementaire sur le sujet
il va saisir le saiser aussi sur le
sujet
comment vous voyez un peu les choses
parce que effectivement il va falloir
travailler sur de la différenciation
mais en même temps il va falloir monter
en conscience collective sur le sujet
quand même à tous les niveaux donc vous
êtes vous un organisme de formation et
d'accompagnement donc c'est un vrai
sujet Comment capitalise
sur quand même
voilà vu la complexité ça mérite quand
même un des travaux vraiment collectifs
on fait comment
écoutez en tant que animateur du ccpqspa
le comité consultatif sur le prix la
qualité de service public de l'eau et de
l'assainissement qui a eu des
maladiations du CNE c'est un sujet dont
nous débattons à chaque réunion il y a
des tas d'expérimentation qui ont été
réalisés sur les tarification sociale on
a suivi de très près et on s'aperçoit là
aussi qui a des difficultés sur le
territoire j'étais encore sur le
territoire du Dunkerquois les
difficultés que celles de service d'eau
pour récupérer les données de la part de
la CAF pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre des
politiques sociales parce qu'il y a la
dimension
en fait c'est politique tarifaire elle
doit avoir un double objectif elles
doivent permettre à chacun d'accéder à
l'eau et donc d'être capable de payer sa
facture d'eau pour l'eau qui consomme
elle doit être aussi elle doit aussi
permettre au service d'avoir un niveau
de recettes qui lui permet de faire face
aux enjeux
d'accélération de l'adaptation au
changement climatique de la réfraction
de la ressource de l'augmentation des
traitements dont on a parlé à cause de
tous les produits qu'on met dans l'Aube
on les met il faut les enlever ça coule
énorme
et
en même temps il faut inciter aux
économies d'eau c'est à dire à chaque
fois que on dit aux gens consommaient
moins d'eau on s'y un peu la branche sur
laquelle on est assise puisque les
recettes du service d'eau sont
proportionnelles au volume consommé donc
c'est un sujet vraiment complexe voilà
donc entre l'accès de tous à l'eau
l'équilibre du système le financement et
puis le financement des agences de l'eau
qui est payé quand même toujours sur la
même facture en bas à droite j'ai
compris mais vous m'avez pas répondu sur
la méthode ça vous va cette méthode du
gouvernement mission d'information
parlementaire saisine du CC
association du CCP qui est proposé
association du ccpqstea j'ai pas entendu
je pense qu'ils ont un peu oublié
Spa vous avez à la fois les services
d'eau les grands services d'eau les
associations de consommateurs les
agriculteurs les industriels il y a tout
le monde
vous êtes quand même d'accord que on
peut pas maintenir des tarifications
dégressives
parce que j'entends les spécificités les
analyses mais on a quand même des
exemples inversés avec des tarifications
dégressifs qui ça il faut l'interdire
tout de suite
on est tous d'accord c'est inciter à
consommer plus c'est même plus
anachronique c'est là c'est ridicule
oui en deux mots effectivement on a eu
beaucoup d'expérimentations sur la
tarification sociale notamment mais en
fait on a très peu on a beaucoup de
tarifications incitatives sociales etc
on a très peu d'évaluation en fait des
effets positifs et négatifs de ces
tarifications et donc voilà ça c'est un
sujet justement
on est en cours de discussion justement
pour travailler aussi là dessus et c'est
un sujet aussi que club des économies
d'eau porte mais je vais laisser Hervé
conclure
c'est vrai que on n'est pas super c'est
difficile aujourd'hui de montrer que la
politique tarifaire a vraiment un levier
sur la diminution de la consommation
d'eau
il y a personne qui l'a démontré
aujourd'hui par contre c'est c'est un
levier je pense que c'est un levier plus
psychologique
on se rend compte en fait que sans
sensibilisation la tarification n'a que
peu d'impact sur les consommations c'est
pas la tarification c'est la
sensibilisation
je prends l'exemple cet été l'été
dernier
parce que c'est pas assez cher peut-être
certainement je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
prix de l'eau n'est pas à sa juste
valeur on peut pas mener à bien les
politiques ambitieuses qu'on a décrite
pendant toute notre entretien
en ayant encore aujourd'hui des
collectivités dans le 7 slogan c'est
l'eau la moins chère de France quand
c'est corrélé à l'accès
puisqu'il y a deux paramètres le coût et
le fait d'avoir accès à la ressource ou
au volume donc c'est avec justement
l'objectif de la directive eau potable
d'accès à l'eau
oui mais ça c'est l'accès pour les pour
les petits mini
pour un usager industriel
l'importance va être d'autant plus forte
qu'il a accès à un volume de ressources
si on lui dit qu'il aura accès à une
ressource moindre parce que il y en a la
notion même de l'importance de ces
usages vous voyez
bien sûr parce que parce que
l'industriel si c'est que
l'été on risque de lui couper l'eau 12
heures par jour peut-être qu'il va
réfléchir à un process qui va optimiser
sa consommation d'eau pour la diminuer
au maximum alors que s'il suffit de
payer quelques centimes de plus le mètre
cube on laisse les vannes ouvertes on
est bien d'accord
les mots de conclusion
d'abord merci merci de nous avoir de
nous avoir reçus et écouter
attentivement ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que on voit bien à travers tous les
échanges qu'on a eu que la politique de
l'eau c'était une politique globale donc
on peut pas la traiter segment par
segment et répondre à chaque question de
façon binaire parce que c'est bien ce
que c'est pas bien il faut avoir
vraiment cette vision d'ensemble et puis
on a découvert c'était pas le cas que ce
sont des politiques de long terme c'est
à dire que les Romains construisaient
des adultes avant de construire des
villes
et aujourd'hui on veut régler par des
mesures en 6 mois les problèmes
d'alimentation en eau pour pour les
prochaines décennies donc c'est vraiment
des politiques de long terme donc il
faut se poser et puis
ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
dans les documents aujourd'hui de
partage de la ressource de mobilisation
de la ressource on regarde l'eau qui
était disponible au cours des années
précédentes il faut aujourd'hui vraiment
qu'on regarde l'eau qui sera disponible
demain au moment où on va l'utiliser et
donc il faut anticiper
je voudrais aussi évoquer le point qui
me paraît important et quand on a
beaucoup parlé c'est le fait que la
quantité d'eau disponible et la qualité
de l'eau sont indissociables dès qu'on a
une raréfaction de la ressource on a une
concentration on a une dégradation de la
qualité et c'est l'inverse dans l'autre
sens c'est-à-dire que quand vous prenez
une tempête Alex au mode territoire ben
je peux vous dire que vous dégradez
fortement la qualité de l'eau pendant la
tempête mais après pendant toutes les
autres années avec les restructurations
morphologiques qui font qu'il y a des
sources qui ont disparu carrément c'est
donc quantité qualité c'est
indissociable donc on peut pas raisonner
qu'est-ce que je fais pour améliorer la
qualité de l'eau
il faut vraiment voir tout ça et puis
voilà
l'agriculture c'est pas un sujet connexe
c'est ça fait partie du sujet de l'eau
et le modèle agricole doit être
interrogé je pense que sur les aires
d'alimentation de champ de captage je
l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure
il faut vraiment que dès à présent on
s'engage à supprimer au cours des 10
prochaines années la totalité des
intrants chimiques qui viennent de
dégrader la qualité des masses d'eau
parce que ce qu'on est en train de faire
maintenant c'est un peu la politique des
Shadoks c'est-à-dire je mets un peu plus
de produits je trie je traite un peu
plus je mets un peu plus je trie un peu
plus pas de souci je sais traiter donc
je peux continuer en mettre mais enfin
c'est pas possible enfin c'est pas censé
et je rappelle que ça représente
simplement 3% de l'air de des surfaces
agricoles utiles voilà bien écoutez
merci beaucoup pour pour ces échanges on
aurait aimé passer encore plus de temps
avec vous on a une audition qui
redémarre malheureusement mais comme je
vous l'ai indiqué vraiment sur les
messages éventuellement que vous avez
pas pu nous faire passer on est on sera
vraiment très attentif
voilà par rapport à vos documents et on
se revoit